ARCHULETA AT KANSAS STATE-
FORGES RADFORD BY ADAM CORTEZ
V. DALLY DODD TORONTO EGGMAN
GLAZER WHOSE ALL THIS GROVE
HERZBERG WAY SO HER TADO JONES.
CAN LONGER LAYERED LLEVA ALONE
WIRE MELINDA'S MEN NEWMAN
NIELSEN SUCH A VOTE PAN FORTUNE
TINO ROSSI RUBIO SKINNER STERN
I'M BERG WHITE HOUSE SKI WINNER
WILL. A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WELCOME BACK TO THE SENATE
SENATORS LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.
IF WE CAN FIND OUR DESKS. WE
WILL BEGIN TODAY'S SESSION. A
LOT OF WORK TO DO TODAY AND FOR
THE NEXT FOUR WEEKS. YOUR
ATTENTION IS GREATLY
APPRECIATED. WITH THE MEMBERS
AND THE GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG BY SENATOR ROB.
SENATOR GONZALES THANK YOU
GRACIOUS AND LOVING GOD. YOU
BACK INTO US FROM A FUTURE
ABUNDANT GRACE FULL OF
CHALLENGE AND RICH IN
POSSIBILITY. IN THE COMING
MONTHS WE ASK YOU FOR THE
GRACE. TO LIVE DEEPLY WITH
PURPOSE. TO LIVE FREELY WITH
ATTACHMENT. TO LIVE WISELY WITH
HUMILITY. TO LIVE JUSTLY WITH
COMPASSION. TO LIVE LOVINGLY
WITH FIDELITY. TO LIVE
MINDFULLY WITH CONSCIOUSNESS.
TO LIVE GRATEFULLY WITH
GENEROSITY. TO LIVE FULLY WITH
ENTHUSIASM. ALL WE DO THESE
DAYS BEFORE THE TRANSFER
INFORMATION OF HEARTS AND
RELATIONSHIPS AND THE GREATEST
UNFOLDING OF ALL CREATION.
PHYLLIS WITH YOUR PIECE AS WE
LOOK TO THE PAST WITH GRATITUDE
LIVE WITH THE PRESENTS WITH
PASSION AND EMBRACE THE FUTURE
WITH HOPE. WE ASK THIS IN YOUR
NAME AMEN. AMEN CENTERS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE AS WE REMEMBER THOSE
SERVING IN AFGHANISTAN. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. ARE ALL.
THANK YOU SENATOR GONZALES AND
SENATOR ROUGH. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
THE COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED
RED AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR THE WEEK OF JULY TWELFTH
THROUGH FIFTEEN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WILL BE APPROVED AND
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
PURSUANT TO RULE TWENTY NINE
POINT ONE ZERO SEE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS BILL IS
RECOMMENDED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE FILE AND ONE ZERO TWO
EIGHT B. FIFTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
FILE ITEM WILL BE STRICKEN FROM
THE FILE ITEM ONE OH FIVE. AMY
SEEKER DALLAS. THERE ARE FLOOR
AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK THEY
WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED. AND
THAT CONCLUDES MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED FOR MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. AND OR TO REMOVE
THINGS FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
REMOVED FROM CONSENT SENATOR
DODD. QUESTION THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE THE FOLLOWING
BILLS FROM THE CONSECUTIVE
PLACE THEM ON THE THIRD READING
AB ELEVEN FIFTY FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTY. AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY SIX FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTY THREE AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
FOUR THANK YOU SENATOR DODD DO
WE GET ALL THOSE. GENERAL
CENTER WINNER. THANK YOU TO
PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR- PLEASE REMOVE AT ELEVEN
FORTY FROM CONSENTS ITEM NUMBER
ONE ITEM NUMBER. TWO ZERO FOUR
EIGHT ELEVEN FORTY ITEMS TO-
FOR. THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER.
ANY OTHER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
CONSENT. THE MOVING ON WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
MEMBERS IF WE CAN BRING OUR
ATTENTION TO THE FLOOR PLEASE
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
FOR SECOND READING- SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILLS OF
FIVE OH TWO WITH AMENDMENTS
NINE SEVENTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SIX ONE
TWENTY TWO. TO THIRTY TWO TO
FORTY FIVE. THREE OH FOUR
READING WILL BE DEEMED BREAD.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS
WILL NEED OUR ATTENTION ON THE
FLOOR. SENATOR BATES WILL
PRESENT GOVERNORS APPOINTMENTS
SENATOR BATES YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
WILL BEGIN A FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE TOWN WHICH IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF SIVA BOONDOCK
FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
PRIOR TO HIS THIS ROLE HE WAS
PART OF THE COMMISSION'S
EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP. SERVING
AS DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF S. I.
ENERGY ENERGY ASSESSMENT
DIVISION HE WAS APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON JULY SEVENTH
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS APPOINTEE. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
AT KINS BY FAITH HI I. BECKER
HI OR JUST. BRADFORD I HAVE A
YELLOW I PROTESTING I DALLY.
DODD I THERE ALSO HI EGGMAN
FIVE GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES I
DROVE FIVE HURTS BERG HI WHERE
SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES. CAN
LONGER HI LAYERED I. LEIVA. HI
THE MON I MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN BY A
SHOW OF BOTH. I CAN FIVE
FOURTEEN TINA. I. ROSS HI RUBIO
I SKINNER. HI STERN HI AM BERG.
WHITE HOUSE SKI HI I. WINNER I
WILL. HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FOR JUST. DALLY JONES.
MELINDA'S AMBERG. HIGHS THIRTY
FIVE NO ZERO APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO ITEM FILE FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE ELEVEN SENATOR BATES THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT PILOT OF
NUMBER ELEVEN IS A CONFIRMATION
OF MARRIED LESLIE AND JAN STORY
TO THE INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATOR GOVERNING BOARD MISS
LESLIE WAS FIRST APPOINTED TO
THE BOARD IN TWENTY NINETEEN
SHE HAS BEEN PRESIDENT OF THE
LOS ANGELES BUSINESS COUNCIL
SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN MISSOURI IS
THE NEW APPOINTEE ON THE BOARD
PRIOR TO THIS APPOINTMENT SHE
WAS A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES OF THE NORTH AMERICAN
ELECTRIC RELIABILITY
CORPORATION. THESE APPOINTEES
WERE BOTH APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JULY SEVENTH FIVE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOAT. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT BRIEFLY I JUST WANTED
TO- GIVE A STRONG
RECOMMENDATION ON BEHALF OF
MERRY AND THE LAST IS BEEN A
FRIEND OF MINE FOR DECADES AND-
HOW I HOLD IN THE HIGHEST
REGARD EXCEPTIONALLY COMPETENT
ANYTHING THAT SHE WORKS AS A
GOOD JOB SO FAR. AND I'M JUST
AS STRONGLY STAND IN SUPPORT OF
HER- APPOINTMENT HERE TODAY
THANK YOU CENTERS BRING ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS APPOINTEE SEEING NONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI FIVE ARCHULETA. I
ADKINS. HI BABES. HI BECKER HI
HI FORGES. BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM FIVE THIRTY FIVE DALLY.
DODD I- ALSO HI A GIVEN I
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE I DROVE.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
FIVE JONES. CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE MOON. HI
WIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN
I NELSON I WOULD SHOW UP BOTH I
CAN I FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS HI
RUBIO. HI SKINNER. HI STERN HI
AM BERG. WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER I WILL. HI PLEASE CALL
THE UP THE MEMBERS. PORGES
VALLEY. GROVE I JONES.
MELINDA'S AMBERG. HIGHS THIRTY
FIVE NO ZERO APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED OR MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTEEN SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE THIRTEEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF VERNON WILLIAMS
TO THE STATE ATHLETIC
COMMISSION JACQUELYN CRABTREE
TO THE BOARD OF BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY. ELLIE KLAAS
BRUCKNER TO THE BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION AND JANET
CAP MEYER AND GEORGE CAN LINE
TO THE MINING AND GEOLOGY BOARD
THESE APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON JULY
SEVENTH. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THESE ITEMS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THESE APPOINTEES.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS HI
BABY. HI BACKER. I PORCHES HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM
HYPERTENSIVE HI DALLY. HI TODD.
HI TORONTO I AGREE IN. ADMIN HI
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE I GROW. HI
HURTS BERG I WEAR SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LABOR. HI THE MON I
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S I MEN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I CHOSE BOTH.
HI PAM HI FOUR TWENTY NOW I.
ROSS I RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN.
HI AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER I WILL. HI THIS CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS. NIELSEN I
AMBERG. HIGHS THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WE'RE MOVING ON TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS BUSINESS FOR TODAY- WE
HAVE TWO ITEMS ON UNFINISHED
BUSINESS WE'RE GING TO GO TO
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY ONE FIRST.
SENATOR MAN ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR ONE TWENTY ONE SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY ONE BY SENATOR MAN AN
ACT RELATING TO COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS IN DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE OF SIGNIFICANTLY
CENTERMAN. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT SP THREE NINETY
ONE BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY FOR
A CONCURRENCE VOTE. AS A
REMINDER THIS BILL SIMPLY
ALLOWS COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS. INCLUDING H. AWAY
BOARD TO SAFELY MEET VIA
TELECONFERENCES DURING
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS.
ENSURES THAT FAIR PARTICIPATION
IN THESE MEETINGS IS ACCESSIBLE
TO MEMBERS. WE RECENTLY ADOPTED
AMENDMENTS NARROWING THE BILL
TO APPLY ONLY WHEN THE NATURE
OF THE OFFICIALLY DECLARED
MURDER EMERGENCY MAKES IT
UNSAFE TO MEET IN PERSON- THIS
COMMON SENSE LEGISLATION COMES
AT THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA LAW REVIEW
COMMISSION. AND HAS ENJOYED
BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BOTH
IN THIS HOUSE AND THE ASSEMBLY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM SEEING NONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI I. ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
I FACE. BACKER HI PORGES HI
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
PROTECTING. I DOUBT DALLY I DON.
HI THERE AWESOME. ADMIN. HI
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE HIGH
GROWTH I HEARD SOME BURG I WISH
SO. HER TADO. HI JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA I
LIVE ALONE. I MOBILEIRON.
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON I WOULD SHOW UP BOTH. I
PAM I FOURTEEN TINO. I. ROSS HI
RUBIO I SCANNER. HI STERN HI
AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI. I
WINNER I WILL HI MEMBERS WERE
GONNA GO THROUGH THE ROLE ONE
MORE TIME AND THEN CLOSE THE
ROLE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BAIT I. TORONTO
I WEST SO I. MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S I AMBERG. HIGHS
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO- SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED AND WE'RE GOING
TO FILE AN M. ONE TWENTY FIVE.
OKAY SENATOR CORTESE. APPEARS
TO BE READYING SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SIX THIRTY
FOUR BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
LABOR AND PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT AN ACT RELATING TO
RETIREMENT. SECRETASE YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SP SIX THIRTY FOUR IS
OUR OMNIBUS RETIREMENT SYSTEMS
HOUSEKEEPING BILL. IT'S BACK
FROM THE ASSEMBLY ON
CONCURRENCE THE BILL MAKES
TECHNICAL CONFORMING. AND NON
CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES TO
RETIREMENT SYSTEM RELATED
STATUTES ADMINISTERED
RESPECTIVELY BY CAL STIRS
CALPERS IN THIRTY SEVEN ACT
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS WERE REQUESTED. BY
THE SENATE- LABOR AND PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT COMMITTEE
IN THE BILL'S SPONSORS AND THE
AMENDMENTS ARE NON
CONTROVERSIAL MINOR IN
TECHNICAL CHANGES ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR CORTESE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. THIS
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION OR- TO A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. I HAD MAJOR PAST-
CONSISTENT AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN THIRTY NINE ICE
KNOWS ZERO PUTTING ON THE FILE
AND ONE THIRTY TWO. WEHAVE
SENATOR RUBIO FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIBSON'S SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON
RELATIVE TO NATIONAL GUN
VIOLENCE AWARENESS DAY SENATOR
RUBIO THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
A C. R. EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH
PROCLAIMS JUNE FOURTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AS NATIONAL GUN
VIOLENCE AWARENESS DAY. EVERY
DAY MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
AMERICANS ARE KILLED BY GUN
VIOLENCE ALONGSIDE MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY WHO ARE
SHOT AND WOUNDED CALIFORNIA
ALONE SEES ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
GUN FATALITIES EVERY YEAR AND
ACCORDING TO THE GIFFORDS LAW
CENTER WE SEE NEARLY FORTY
THOUSAND KILLINGS TO. TO GUN
VIOLENCE AND THE OCCUR
NATIONWIDE. MURDERS THAT OCCUR
IN OUR STREETS AND IN OUR HOMES
AT WORK AND IN HIGH END SCHOOLS
MOVIE THEATERS AND EVEN
CHURCHES ARE UNACCEPTABLE. WE
MUST CONTINUE TO WORK AGAINST
THESE HEINOUS CRIMES BECAUSE
THESE ARE NOT JUST NUMBERS ON
PAPER THESE ERRORS SOMEONE'S
FAMILY SOMEONE'S FATHER
DAUGHTER MOTHER. WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO PUSH HARDER TO MAKE
CHANGES THAT ARE POSITIVE AND
KEEP OUR LOVE ONES ALIVE. THESE
ARE THOUSANDS OF LIVES WERE
TAKEN TALKING ABOUT THE COVER
NINETY PANDEMIC HAS ONLY MADE
CIRCUMSTANCES EVEN WORSE. MY
HEART STOPS EACH AND EVERY
SINGLE TIME I HEAR SOMEONE'S
FAMILY MEMBER LOST TO GUN
VIOLENCE. I COMMEND THE RECENT
STRIKES MADE BY THE BITE IN A
MINISTRATION AND TO ARE
HONORABLE GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
FOR PRIORITIZING GUN. VIOLENCE
PREVENTION FUNDING THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PROGRAM TOGETHER
WE CAN CONTINUE TO INCREASE
AWARENESS OF THIS TERRIBLE
ISSUE FACING OUR COMMUNITIES
AND WORK. ENVIRONMENTS AND TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF GUN
FATALITIES IN OUR STATE AND
NATION. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIFLE. THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI I. ARCHULETA
I ATKINS I FACE I BACKER HI
FORGES HI BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM I OR TEN THIRTY FIVE DALLY.
I DON. HI THERE ARE SO HI
AIKMAN I GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES I GROSS RD HURTS
BERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO I
JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I
LABOUR HI THE MON. HI MCGUIRE.
I MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. A SHOW OF BOTH. I CAN
I FORTINO I. ROSS I REVIEW HI
SKINNER. I STERN I AM BERG
WHITE HOUSE SKI. I WINNER I
WILL HI PLEASE CALL THE OFFICE
MEMBERS. NIELSEN I AMBERG.
HIGHS THIRTY NINE DOES ZERO
MAJOR PASSES WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO FILE AND ONE FORTY SEVEN.
WE HAVE CENTER WINNER FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
SIXTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEE
AN ACT RELATED TO MOBILE HOMES.
CENTER WINNER. THANK YOU-
COLLEAGUES A. B. TEN SIXTY ONE
OVER TEXAS MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS FROM ON JUST WATER
SERVICE CHARGES CURRENTLY MANY
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS ARE
CHARGED AMBIGUOUS QUOTE UNQUOTE
WATER SERVICE FEES FROM THEIR
PARK OWNERS AT ALL OFTEN
INCREASE WITHOUT ANY
EXPLANATION MAYBE TEN SIXTY ONE
WILL CORRECT- THIS PROBLEM BY
ENSURING THAT MOBILE HOME PARK
RESIDENTS. CAN ONLY BE CHARGED.
SEES ME THEIR PROPORTIONAL
SHARE OF PARKER'S WATER CHARGES
PLUS A REASONABLE SERVICE AND
MANAGEMENT FEE. AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CLARIFY THAT NOTHING
IN THE BILL WHAT WILL PREVENT
MOBILE HOME PARKS IN RECOVERING
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE PARKS
WATER SYSTEM THROUGH OTHER
MEANS. WILL BE TEN SIXTY ONE
WAS FOR THE MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS ARE NOT PROFITEERING OFF
OF PROVIDING THE RESIDENTS WITH
WATER I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
ITEM. THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER
THIS ITEM. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI ADKINS HI BABIES. BACKER FOR
JUST. NO BRADFORD I HAVE A I
DON'T. KORD HEAVY HI DALLY.
DODD HI TORONTO HI EGGMAN I
GLAZER. GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE.
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HURTADO
JONES. CAMCORDER I LAYERED I
LLEVA I LIVE MON I MAGUIRE. I
MELINDA'S. MAN. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH. PAN.
HI FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS FIVE
RUBIO HI SKINNER. I STERN I AM
BERG. WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER
I WILL HI HI. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BAIT BACKER.
CABRERO. DALLY NO. GLAZER I
GROVE NO WESO I HER TADO. JONES
I. MELINDA'S MAN. CONTROL OF
BOTH. AMBERG SENATOR WILK. I
DON'T KNOW WELL I DON'T KNOW.
HIGHS TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS FIVE
THE MEASURE PASSES. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM. ONE FIFTY. WE HAVE
SENATOR HERZBERG FOR ASSEMBLY
RAMEAU'S SECRETARYPLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FIFTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST AN ACT
RELATED COURTS. THE CENTERS FOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT OF THIS MEASURE. WILL
ALLOW FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER
THE FIRST TIME EVER
CALIFORNIA'S JUDICIAL BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT. POLICE TO
COMMEMORATE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN DAY IN LIEU OF
COLUMBUS DAY. IN CITIES ACROSS
THE NATION THERE'S A GROWING
AWARENESS OF OUR COLLECTIVE IN
VIOLENT HISTORY. END OF THE
LEGACIES THAT REVERBERATE IN
OUR JUSTICE HEALTH. EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEMS BY ALLOWING THE
JUDICIAL PERSONNEL TO HONOR AND
CELEBRATE THE STATE'S NATIVE
POPULATION WE'RE BRINGING
KNOWLEDGE MEANT. TO THEIR
IMPORTANT HISTORY. BUT TO BE
CLEAR THIS IS NOT ABOUT TEARING
DOWN HISTORY WE CANNOT CHANGE
THE PAST MEMBERS INSTEAD WE ARE
REMAINING WE ARE REIMAGINING A
HALL OF THE BOARD OF THE PAST
TO REPRESENT NEW VALUES. OF OUR
FUTURE. THE DISCOVERY OF
AMERICA. IS SOMETHING WE WANT
TO GET RIGHT TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND AND TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHO WE ARE
AS A NATION WE MUST MAKE IT
CLEAR ABOUT WHO WE WERE FIRST.
AND REFLECT ON WHAT HAPPENED IN
OUR HISTORY. THIS MEASURE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROB MOST IS
HISTORIC STEP. IN CELEBRATING
AND HONORING CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
PEOPLE. WHOSE HISTORY CULTURE
CONTRIBUTIONS HAVE LARGELY BEEN
IGNORED I ASKED FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM SENATOR HUESO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS.
YOU KNOW I HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT
THIS BILL QUITE A BIT AND IT'S-
AND IT'S COST ME. QUITE A BIT
OF CONSTERNATION. AND ON ON THE
SURFACE THIS BILL SEEMS. LIKE A
VERY SIMPLE BILL THAT THIS
LEADS TO THE BILL ABOUT.
HONORING NATIVE AMERICANS. AND
FOR THAT WE SHOULD HONOR NATIVE
AMERICANS AND THE HISTORY. THIS
SHOULD THIS SHOULD THIS BILL
SHOULD ONLY BE ABOUT CREATING A
MONUMENT. FOR NATIVE AMERICANS
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL SHOULD BE.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS NOT WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT. AND FOR
THAT I HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT THIS
QUITE A BIT. AND I'VE HAD QUITE
A BIT OF HEARTBURN OVER THIS
BILL. AND I'LL TELL YOU WHY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. OF
THIS BILL INTENDS TO REMOVE A
MONUMENT. FROM OUR CAPITOL
GROUNDS A MONUMENT THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT. THE MONUMENT THAT
MAKES CENTER WAY SO IF I CAN
JUST INTERRUPT YOU REAL QUICK I
THINK THE AUTHOR MIGHT HAVE A
QUICK EXPLANATION OF WHERE
WE'RE AT ON THIS. PROJECT. I'M
I'M REALLY SORRY I JUST DIDN'T
EXPECT FOR THIS BILL TO COME UP
WITH IT. OKAY I WAS TOLD WE
WEREN'T HERE BILLS TODAY BUT- I
WANT TO APOLOGIZE TO THE SENATE
AND TO THE PUBLIC SORRY. IN A
WAY SO THANK YOU- WE WILL HAVE
A GREAT EXPECTATION OF VERY
ELOQUENT SPEECH WHEN THAT- THAT
BILL COMES UP THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. PLEASE GERMAN WERE
ON FILE AND ONE FIFTY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WAY SO ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT FIFTY FIVE. IS THERE
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM BEFORE I ALLOW
THIS AUTHOR TO CLOSE. SENATOR
HERTZBERG YOU MAKE CLOSE
BRIEFLY MISTER MISTER PRESIDENT
THIS BUILD NOT. REMOVE COLUMBUS
DAY IS A HOLIDAY ALL TOGETHER
IT'S SIMPLY BRING SINCE IT THE
STATE COURTS I LINE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE AND EXECUTIVE
BRANCHES BY NOT MAKING COLUMBUS
DAY PAID HOLIDAY OFF IN THE
FORM. OF A JUDICIAL HOLIDAY.
LAST YEAR I'VE- THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG'S SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS HI BABY I
BACKER FIVE FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD HI COME BY ADAM HI
COURTESY. HI DALLY. DOT I
TORONTO I EGGMAN. I GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE I GROW. HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. HER TADO HI JONES.
CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA I
LIVE MON. I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN OCHO A
BOAT I CAN. I FORTUNE TINO.
ROTH HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. I
STERN I AM BERG. WHITE HOUSE
SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL. HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DALLY GROVE. WAY SO. JONES
MELINDA'S. NIELSEN FOURTEEN
TINO. AMBERG HIGHS THIRTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO MAJOR PASSES MEMBERS
WERE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY SEVEN FILED BY
FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY. FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN IS SENATOR LEYVA FOR-
SOMEONE MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION FOURTEEN BY
FAMILY MEMBER BURNER **** BATH
RELATIVE TO TITLE NINE SENATOR
LEYVA THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AGES ARE
FOURTEEN WOULD COMMEMORATE THE
FORTY NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF
TITLE NINE PROTECTIONS AGAINST
SEX BASED DISCRIMINATION IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND WOULD URGE
CALIFORNIANS TO CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER TO ACHIEVE ITS
GOALS OF MORE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR YOUTH
MEMBERS AS YOU KNOW TITLE NINE
IS A CIVIL RIGHTS LAW THAT ALL
ELEMENTARY SECONDARY SCHOOLS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. RECEIVING FEDERAL
FUNDING MUST COMPLY WITH THESE
PROTECTIONS HAVE BEEN CRITICAL
OF FOSTERING THE SUCCESS OF
YOUNG WOMEN FOR THE PAST FORTY
NINE YEARS WELL ILLUSTRATING
THE VALUE OF STUDENT
PROTECTIONS TODAY UNFORTUNATELY
THERE ARE SEVENTY EIGHT
CALIFORNIA ELEMENTARY AND
SECONDARY SCHOOLS COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES CURRENTLY UNDER
INVESTIGATION BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION FOR
THEIR HANDLING OF TITLE NINE
CASES OF COURSE THESE
PROTECTIONS HAVE CERTAINLY ALSO
ALLOWED OUR STUDENTS TO THRIVE.
ATHLETIC SUCCESS HAS ALSO BEEN
RECOGNIZED BY TITLE NINE IN AS
IN AS OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
HIGH SCHOOL ATHLETES
PARTICIPATION RATES FOR GIRLS
INCREASED BY MORE THAN 1000%
SINCE THE LAW PASSED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO HOWEVER
CURRENT GIRLS PARTICIPATION
NUMBERS HAVE NEVER REACHED THE
LEVEL OF BOYS PARTICIPATION OF
THE NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE AND
SEVENTY TWO LEVEL IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO ONE TOTAL ON NINE
WAS PASSED BOYS PARTICIPATION
NUMBERS WERE THREE POINT SIX
MILLION WHICH IS THREE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FOUR BY TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND TIMES MORE. THAN GIRLS
PARTICIPATION IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN MEMBERS THE PROMISE OF
TITLE NINE IS IT GUARANTEES
pEDUCATIONAL EQUITY FOR EVERYONE
REGARDLESS OF SEX GENDER
IDENTITY OR GENDER EXPRESSION
WELL THIS LAW HAS CERTAINLY
INCREASED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
GIRLS AND WOMEN IN ACADEMICS
SPORTS AND OTHER EDUCATIONAL
ACTIVITIES IT HAS NOT YET
ACHIEVED THE GOAL OF FULL
QUALITY. AS SUCH AG ARE
FOURTEEN RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANT STRIDES MADE SINCE
TITLE NINE WAS PASSED AND URGES
US TO CONTINUE OUR FIGHT
FORWARD FOR EQUALITY FOR ALL
MEMBERS I URGE AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CENTERS THIS QUALIFIES
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NONE THE MEASURE PASSES HIGHS
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO. MEMBERS
ARE MOVING ON A FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY SENATOR MAN FOR SOME A
MEMBER- ONE. SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN OH
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN AN
ACT RELATING TO COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS. CENTERMAN THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I A. B. ELEVEN
OH ONE WILL PROVIDE CLARITY ON
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS FOR A
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN
AUTHORED AB TWENTY NINE TWELVE
WHICH UPDATED THE TOOLS
AVAILABLE FOR HOAS TO PREVENT
FRAUDULENT ACTIVITIES. SINCE
ITS PASSAGE WE'VE HEARD FROM
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT THE NEED FOR
GREATER CLARITY ON SOME OF THE
TERMS. IT'S A TECHNICAL CLEANUP
MEASURE MEANT TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THESE CONCERNS AND ENSURE
THAT OUR EFFORTS TO COMBAT
FRAUD OR CLEAR SO THE HOAS CAN
EFFECTIVELY PROTECT THEIR
FUNDS. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I HAVE A-
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE THIS ALSO QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE ANIMUS
ROLL CALL SEEING NONE THE
MEASURE PASSES EYES THIRTY NINE
IT KNOWS ZERO MEMBERS ARE
MOVING ON A FILE AND ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN SENATOR WILL FOR A SUMMIT
MEMBER LACKEY SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN OH
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY
AN ACT RELATING TO CANNABIS
CENTER WHAT. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS BEFORE YOU
TODAY'S AB THIRTEEN OH FIVE
WHICH I'M PRESENTING ON BEHALF
OF A CINNAMON TOM LACKEY. UNDER
CURRENT LAW CANNABIS
RESEARCHERS REGISTERED WITH THE
U. S. DRUG ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
D. E. A. ARE FORCED TO VIOLATE
EDA GUIDELINES BY COMPLYING
WITH CALIFORNIA'S MEDICINAL AND
ADULT USE CANNABIS REGULATION
AND SAFETY ACT. THIS BILL
ALLOWS FEDERALLY APPROVED
CANNABIS RESEARCHERS TO COMPLY
WITH DEA GUIDELINES BY
EXEMPTING THEM FROM THAT
MCCURRY SAT. WITHOUT THIS BILL
THESE RESEARCHERS ARE EITHER
VIOLATION OF STATE LAW WE'RE IN
VIOLATION TO D. E. A.
GUIDELINES D. B. THIRTEEN OH
FIVE RECEIVE UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
SUPPORTED BY THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SENATOR WILK ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE THIS ITEM
ALSO QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO ANIMUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NONE OF THE MAJOR PASSES
EYES THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO
WE'RE MOVING ON FILE AND ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH WILL BE
FOLLOWED BY ONE NINETY THREE.
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT A SENATOR HER
TADO FOR ASSEMBLYWOMAN
CALDERONE SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FORTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CALDERONE AN ACT RELATING TO
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. CENTER
TAUGHT. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL. AB FOUR FOUR FIVE BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN WHICH
REMOVES A REQUIREMENT THE
REGIONAL. CENTERS NEED TO
COLLECT PARENT TOLD US SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS AS A CONDITION
FOR PROVIDING SERVICE OLD
FEDERAL FUNDING RULES REQUIRED
REGIONAL CENTERS TO COLLECT
THIS INFORMATION FROM PARENTS
IN ORDER TO SERVE THE CHILDREN.
WHILE THE FEDERAL FUNDING RULES
CHANGE TWO YEARS AGO THE STATE
LAW HAS NOT. SO A. B. FOUR FOUR
FIVE REPEAL THE OUTDATED DATA
COLLECTION REQUIREMENT REMOVING
A SMALL BUT SIGNIFICANT BARRIER
TO SERVICE AND ELIMINATED
BUREAUCRATIC HURDLE RECENT FOR
MOMENTS FOR CLARIFYING AND
REQUESTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES THIS
BILL RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOUS IN HER
TADO ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THING ON THIS ITEM ALSO
QUALIFIES UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ANY OPPOSITION TO UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING NONE NOT
MAJOR PASSES EYES THIRTY NINE
KNOWS ZERO MEMBERS REMOVING ON
A FILE AND I'M ONE NINETY THREE.
WHICH IS SENATOR RUBIO FOR
SILLY WOMAN PETRI NORRIS
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX EIGHTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRI NORRIS AN
ACT RELATING TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SENATOR RUBIO THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY NINE WHICH WILL ALLOW
FOR SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE TO SEEK HELP VIA TAX
AND OTHER COMPUTER BASED
TECHNOLOGIES. DURING THE
PANDEMIC THE STAY AT HOME ORDER
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED FOR
SURVIVORS TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
WAYS TO SEEK HELP WHEN THE
SURVIVORS TRAPPED AT HOME WITH
THEIR ABUSER PHONE CALLS ARE
NOT ALWAYS THE SAFEST WAY TO
REACH OUT FOR HELP OFTENTIMES
TEXAN CHAT LINES OFFER A MUCH
SAFER WAY FOR SURVIVORS TO
CONNECT. WITH SERVICE PROVIDERS
CURRENTLY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CENTERS ARE HAMPERED BY
LIMITATIONS OF THE DEFINITION
FOR PHONE BASED HOTLINES
CALIFORNIA CODE BECAUSE OF THIS
DOMESTIC VOLENCE CENTERS ARE
INELIGIBLE FOR STATE FUNDING
FOR OTHER TYPES OF HOTLINE
SERVICES SUCH AS TAX OR CHAT
LINES THIS WILL HELP MODERNIZE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTERS
REQUIREMENTS TO INCLUDE THE
OPTION OF OTHER TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORMS AND BE BETTER
EQUIPPED TO HELP THOSE SEEKING
HELP. THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGH THE ENTIRE PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IDOL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM SEEING NONE THIS
ALSO QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS. THERE ANY
OPPOSITION GM'S ROLL CALL.
SEEING NONE EITHER MAJOR. EYES
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO MOVING
ON TO FILE AND ONE NINETY EIGHT
WHICH WILL BE FOLLOWED BY TWO
HUNDRED. ONE NINETY EIGHT AS
SENATOR RUBIO FOR SOME MEMBER
CHILD SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN FORTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TRIAL AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTIONS IN
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
SICK BACK TO ME DEALING SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
HAD LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE DR PRICE TO PRESENT AB
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX EIGHT
DISTRICTS SPECIFIC BILL. THAT
WOULD PERMIT THE CITY OF ALL
HAMBRO ON BEHALF OF THE HUMBER
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
CONDUCT A SPECIAL ELECTION TO
PROCEED WITH ITS TRANSITION
FROM AT LARGE TO BITE TRUSTEE
AREA ELECTIONS. FOR MEMBERS OF
THE BOARD OF EDUCATION
CONSISTENT WITH THE ELECTIONS
AND EDUCATION CODE
REQUIREMENTS. DURING THE
NOVEMBER THIRD TWENTY TWENTY
GENERAL ELECTION MEASURE G.
WHICH APPEARED ON THE BALLOT
SOUGHT TO REMOVE FROM THE CITY
CHARTER ALL REFERENCES TO THE
ALHAMBRA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. HOWEVER MEASURED SHE
ONLY APPEARED ON THE BALLOT SO
VOTERS RESIDING IN THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA AND NOT ON THE BALLOT.
BUT VOTERS IN I HAVE A UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT RECITED
OUTSIDE CITY LIMITS. UNDER
EXISTING LAW EIGHT CHARTER
AMENDED. FOR A CITY MUST BE
SUBMITTED TO VOTERS AT AN
ESTABLISHED STATEWIDE GENERAL
ELECTION. HENCE THE CITY OF ALL
HAMBRE. AND AS SUSAN UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE PROHIBITED
FROM CONDUCTING A SPECIAL
ELECTION TO AMEND THE CHARTER
PRIOR TO THE NEXT STATE WIDE
ELECTION. ON NOVEMBER. EIGHTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THANK LOG
FURTHER DELAY THE DISTRICT'S
COMPLETION AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF A TRUSTEE AREA ELECTION
SYSTEM. TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA VOTING
RIGHTS ACT OF TWENTY. I'M SORRY
TWO THOUSAND ONE THEREFORE WE
NEED TO CREATE A SPECIAL
EXEMPTION AND THE GOVERNMENT
CODE TO PERMIT THE CITY OF ALL
HAMBRE. AND A SUIT I'M SORRY-
I'M HAVING IF I TO DISTRICT TO
CONDUCT A SPECIAL ELECTION
BEFORE THE NEXT STATE WIDE
ELECTION. AND TO ACHIEVE THIS
THE BILL HAS AN URGENCY CLAUSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A RIFLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I. ATKINS HI
BABES. BACKER FIVE PORCHES HI
BRADFORD I CAN'T BUY A FIVE OR
TEN THIRTY FIVE DALLY. FIVE DOT
HI THERE ARE SO BY ADMIN I
GLAZER FIVE DOLLARS I GROW. I
HEARD SPURRED BY WESTERN I HER
TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED I LLEVA I LIVE MON I
REQUIRE. HI MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. BUT SHOW BOTH
HI PAM. HI FORTINO HI RALPH I
DO I SCANNER I STERN I AM BERG
WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE WINNER. I
WILL HI PLEASE CALL THE OF THE
MEMBERS. BAYTEX MELINDA'S.
NIELSEN NUMBER. TWO HI IS
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY EYES THIRTY SIX KNOWS
ZERO ON THE MEASURE THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WERE GONNA GO
TO FILE AN M. TWO HUNDRED AND
THEN BACK IN THE FILE TO ONE
THIRTY THREE MOVING ON TO TWO
HUNDRED SENATOR ALAN. FOR
SOMEONE MEMBER COURT. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
NINETY EIGHT BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS AND
ACTUALLY INTO HAZARDOUS WASTE.
CENTRE ALAN BURGESS PRESIDENT
THIS IS A COMMITTEE BILL IT
UPDATES THE LOTTO REFLECT
CHANGES TO THE FEDERAL
HAZARDOUS WASTE GENERATOR
IMPROVEMENT RULE. UPDATED BY
OUR US EPA. THIS INCLUDES
UPDATING NEW TERMS AND SETTING
CORRECT COULD REFERENCES.
RECENT MOMENTS WERE TO ADDRESS
CHOPPING ISSUES THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECT PASSION
ABOUT. THANK YOU SIR ALAN ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. I BELIEVE THIS IS ON.
THIS IS ALSO AVAILABLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION JANICE ROLL CALL.
SEEING NONE HIGHS THIRTY NINE
NO ZERO MAJOR PASSES WE'RE
GONNA MOVE BACK IN THE FILE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO FILE
AND ONE THIRTY THREE. SENATOR
WIENER FIRST IN A MEMBER KYLIE
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SEVENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KYLIE AND AFTER
RELATING TO ENROLLMENT
AGREEMENTS CENTER WINNER I
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT CALLING
FROM PRESENTING EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTY TWO WHICH WILL ENSURE
THE VICTIMS OF CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ASSAULT COULD PURSUE CIVIL
LITIGATION AGAINST THE
PERPETRATOR AND OTHER RELEVANT
PARTIES THE BILL ORIGINATED
FROM A RECENT CASE INVOLVING
THE BRENTWOOD SCHOOL IN LOS
ANGELES. WHERE A STUDENT WAS
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS BY HIS CHEMISTRY
TEACHER WHILE THE TEACHER WAS
CRIMINALLY PROSECUTED AND SERVE
JAIL TIME THE VICTIMS OF CIVIL
CLAIM WAS FORCED INTO
ARBITRATION BY THE SCHOOL.
BASED ON THE ENROLLMENT
AGREEMENT THAT HIS PARENTS HAD
SIGNED WHICH INCLUDED AN
ARBITRATION CLAUSE MAYBE TWO
SEVENTY TWO WILL RECTIFY THIS-
AND WILL PROVIDE THAT OUR
TEACHER TOLD PUBLIC OR PRIVATE
SCHOOL CANNOT FORCE A VICTIM OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT IN
ARBITRATION AGAINST THEIR WILL.
ON THE LEGISLATURE TO TAKE
ACTION TO RESTORE THE RIGHT TO
TRANSPARENT A CIVIL LITIGATION
PROCESS EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY TWO
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT BOTH HOUSES AND HAS
NOT RECEIVED AN OVER I ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS FILE ITEM.
SITTING ON THIS IS ALSO QUALIFY
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NONE HIGHS THIRTY NINE KNOWS
ZERO MAJOR PASSES. BASIN JOHN
THAT CONCLUDES OUR FILE ITEMS
FOR TODAY WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS
SINNER PORTENT TINO. D. A.
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
MEET AT THREE O'CLOCK IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE RECONVENE.
THANK YOU SENATOR FORTINO
APPROPRIATIONS AT THREE O'CLOCK.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE BACK
TO- MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS FOR
THE GERMANS IN MEMORY LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN SENATORS. I'M
SORRY SENATOR MELINDA DID YOU
WANNA BE RECOGNIZED FOR OCEANS
AND RESOLUTIONS I APOLOGIZE
CENTER MELINDA'S. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- HI RES. UNDER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE TWENTY EIGHT TO
WITHDRAW SCR FIVE FROM THE
SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE BROUGHT
TO THE SENATE FLOOR THAT WE MAY
HAVE A FULL AND RIGOROUS DEBATE
TWO WEEKS TO FLATTEN THE CURVE.
HAS TURNED INTO FIVE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY ONE DAYS. OKAY WE
HAVE MORE THAN 60% OF THE
POPULATION CALIFORNIA WHO WANTS
A VACCINATION FOR KEVIN
NINETEEN THEY CAN GET ONE
EVERYBODY WANTS ONE ESSENTIALLY
AT THIS POINT. HAS GOTTEN ONE
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY ONE DAYS
WE'VE BEEN UNDER THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY WHICH CLEARLY ISN'T
NECESSARY AND NECESSARY MORE
GIVEN. THE FACT THAT OUR KIDS
ARE BACK TO SCHOOL THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE OUR BUSINESSES
THAT ARE RE OPENING UNDER SOME
MODIFIED CONDITIONS. THANK YOU.
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY ONE DAYS IS
LONG ENOUGH AND ALL I'M ASKING
IS THAT THIS BILL IS ALLOWED.
TO BE HEARD AND TO BE DEBATED
AND TO BE VOTED UPON AND IF YOU
WANT TO VOTE AGAINST IT VOTE
AGAINST IT AND IF YOU WANT TO
VOTE FOR IT VOTE FOR IT TO TAKE
A STAND ONE WAY OR THE OTHER
THAT'S ALL I'M ASKING FOR. I
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU SIR MELINDA'S SENATOR
HERTZBERG. YES I TAKE A STAND
TO ASK FOR A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTERS FOR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN SENATOR
MELINDA IS ASKING FOR AND I
VOTE. SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN NO
ARCHULETA NO AT KINS NO FAITH I
BACKER. NO FOR JUST. HI
BRADFORD NO BY ADAM NO CORTEZ
NO DALLY. I DON NO THEY'RE
AWESOME NO EGGMAN NO LASER. NO
GONZALEZ. NO GROWTH. HI HURTS
BURKE. NO WAY SO NO HER TADO NO
JONES I CAN LONGER NO LAYERED
NO LLEVA NO THE MON. NO MCGUIRE.
NO MELINDA'S I MEN. NO NEWMAN
NO NIELSEN I COULD SHOW BOTH I
PAN NO FORTUNE TINO NO BROTH.
NO RUBIO NO SKINNER NO STERN NO
AMBERG WITE HOUSE SKI NO
WINNER. NO WELL HI. HIGHS NINE
IT KNOWS THIRTY THE MOTION
FAILS. MEMBERS CENTER REDFORD
UNDER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS. BUT
THEN I REQUESTED A V. NINE
FOURTEEN BE REMOVED FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR THANK YOU SIR BYE
FOR ANY OTHER CONSENT. REMOVALS.
K. CENTERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO THE GERMANS IN MEMORY OF WE
CAN ALL TAKE OUR SEATS AND
GIVE. OUR ATTENTION TO THE
SPEAKERS THAT WILL BE GIVING
THEIR GERMANS IN MEMORY. WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH SENATOR
ATKINS WHO HAS TWO
PRESENTATIONS THIS MORNING
SENATOR ACTIONS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF TWO GREAT HEROES FROM
SAN DIEGO WHO SERVED OUR
COUNTRY. RETIRED MARINE COLONEL
DAVE SEVERANCE AND RETIRED NAVY
CHIEF PETTY OFFICER STUART
NOBLE HEADLEY. COLONEL
SEVERANCE A MAN OF GREAT VALOR
AND DISTINCTION DIED AT THE AGE
OF A HUNDRED AND TWO ON AUGUST
SECOND. BORN IN MILWAUKEE HE
GREW UP IN COLORADO AND JOINED
THE MARINES IN NINETEEN THIRTY
EIGHT. BRINGING HIM TO SAN
DIEGO FOR BOOT CAMP. SEVEN
YEARS LATER COLONEL SEVERANCE
LEAD TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY MEN
AND SIX OFFICERS FROM CAMP
PENDLETON. TO A SMALL ISLAND
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILES OFF
THE COAST OF JAPAN. INTO THE
BATTLE OF IWO JIMA. FOR MANY OF
US AND I COMIC IN ICONIC IMAGE
COMES TO MIND WHEN WE HEAR YOU
WOULD TEAM UP. AN IMAGE OF SIX
MARINES RAISING THE AMERICAN
FLAG. THE FAMOUS PHOTO IS THE
MODEL FOR THE U. S. MARINE
CORPS WAR MEMORIAL IN ARLINGTON
VIRGINIA. AND WAS FEATURED IN
THE TWO THOUSAND SIX MOVIE
FLAGS OF OUR FATHERS. IN FACT
COLONEL SEVERANCE CONSULTANT ON
THE FILM AND WAS THE
INSPIRATION FOR ONE OF THE
CHARACTERS. WHAT MANY DO NOT
KNOW AND WHAT COLONEL SEVERIN
SPENT HIS LIFE TRYING TO
CLARIFY. IS THAT THE PHOTO
ACTUALLY SHOWS THE SECOND
AMERICAN FLAG RAISED ON MOUNT
SURIBACHI THAT DAY. THE FIRST
FLAG WAS RAISED EARLIER ON HIS
ORDERS. FALL COLONEL SEVERANCE
DID NOT KNOW THE BATTLE WOULD
CONTINUE FOR THIRTY ONE MORE
pDAYS AFTER THE FLAG WAS RAISED
HE DIDN'T KNOW THAT SEEING IT
WAVE OVER THE ISLAND WOULD BE A
MORALE BOOST. AND IT WAS FOR
THOSE ON THE FIELD AND THOSE
BACK HOME. REFLECTING ON THE
HISTORIC MOMENT YEARS LATER HE
SAID THE FLAG WAS A SYMBOL OF
THE COURAGE AND SACRIFICE. THE
MARINES SHOWED ON THAT
BATTLEFIELD. TODAY BOTH FLAGS
LAY IN THE NATIONAL MUSEUM OF
THE MARINE CORPS. ALONG WITH A
NOTE AMENDING THE HISTORICAL
RECORD TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT TWO
FLAGS. PLAYED A ROLE IN THE
STORY. I KNOW THAT COLONEL
SEVERANCE FOUGHT HARD TO SEE
COME TO FRUITION. HE WAS
AWARDED THE SILVER STAR AFTER
THE BATTLE AND WE GO ON TO
RECEIVE THE DISTINGUISHED
FLYING CROSS. AS A COMBAT PILOT
IN THE KOREAN WAR. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS TWO DAUGHTERS
NINA AND LAND TWO SONS DAVE
JUNIOR AND MIKE. SEVERAL
GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. RETIRED NAVY
CHIEF PETTY OFFICER STUART
NOBLE HEADLEY FINALLY NOTICED
TWO DIED FROM COMPLICATIONS OF
CODE NINETEEN ON AUGUST FOURTH.
JUST EIGHTY SIX DAYS SHY OF HIS
HUNDREDTH BIRTHDAY. BORN IN
FLORIDA RAISED IN BUFFALO NEW
YORK. HEADLEY WAS INSPIRED TO
SERVE FROM A YOUNG AGE AT JUST
FOUR FEET ELEVEN INCHES HE WAS
TURNED DOWN BY THE NAVY WHEN HE
FIRST TRIED TO JOIN. AFTER
BUILDING SOME MUSCLE AND MENTAL
FORTITUDE SERVING IN THE
CIVILIAN CONSERVATION CORPS.
AND GROWING A FEW INCHES HE
TRIED AGAIN AND WAS FINALLY
ABLE TO TAKE THE OATH OF OFFICE
IN NINETEEN FORTY. ON DECEMBER
SEVENTH NINETEEN FORTY ONE
CHIEF HEADLEY WAS SITTING. IN
THE USS WEST VIRGINIA AT PEARL
HARBOR WHEN A JAPANESE SHOW
BLEW THROUGH THE SIDE OF THE
BOAT. JUST BARELY MISSING HIM
HE WAS ABLE TO ESCAPE BY
JUMPING INTO THE WATER AND
SWIMMING THROUGH OIL AND FLAMES
WHILE THE ATTACK RAGED ON.
AFTER SERVING OUR COUNTRY IN
THE NAVY FOR TWENTY YEARS HE
RETIRED AND SPENT ANOTHER TWO
DECADES SERVING OUR COMMUNITY.
WITH THE LEMAY SAID SPRING
VALLEY SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE CHIEF
HADLEY WAS FUELED BY A DUTY TO
SEE THAT THE TWO THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED AND THREE PEOPLE WHO
LOST THEIR LIVES THAT FATEFUL
DECEMBER DAY. DID NOT DO SO
INVADING. A MEMBER OF THE SAN
DIEGO CHAPTER OF THE PEARL
HARBOR SURVIVORS ASSOCIATION.
HE REGULARLY SPOKE AT SCHOOLS
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS AND
VETERANS EVENTS TELLING THE
STORY OF THAT DAY AND THE
LESSONS HE LEARNED FROM THE
WAR. HE EMBODIED THE CHAPTERS
MOTTO REMEMBER PEARL HARBOR
KEEP AMERICA ALERT. SURVIVED BY
HIS DAUGHTERS BARBARA PATTY AND
NANCY AND HIS SON RIGHT. I THAT
IS CERTAINLY- IN SAN DIEGO STEW
IS ONE OF THE VERY FINAL
MEMBERS OF THE PEARL HARBOR
SURVIVORS. COLONEL SEVERANCE
AND CHIEF HADLEY WERE HEROES
PATRIOTS AND KEEPERS OF OUR
HISTORY AS THE NUMBER OF WORLD
WAR TWO SURVIVORS DWINDLES
THEIR DEATH SYMBOLIZED THE END
OF AN ERA THAT WE MUST NOT
FORGET. COLLEAGUES TO ASK YOU
TO JOIN ME IN RECOGNITION OF
THE LOGS AND THE SERVICE THESE
TWO MILITARY VETERANS OF THE
GREATEST GENERATION GAVE TO OUR
COUNTRY. THANK YOU SIR RECKONS
I JOIN UNION GERMAN MEMORY FOR
TWO AMERICAN. AND SAN DIEGO HE
ROSE FROM THE MERIT HIS
GREATEST GENERATION THANK YOU.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT DIED CHARM IN THE
MEMORY OF A- LONG STANDING I
THINK THE LONGEST STANDING
MEMBER OF CONGRESS IN HIS PARTY
WHICH IS NOT MY PARTY. BUT HE
WAS A GOOD MAN AND A WONDERFUL
PUBLIC SERVANT. I MET HIM FIRST
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF REDLANDS
WHEN HE SERVED IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE BEFORE
HE WENT TO CONGRESS IN THE
SEVENTIES. I DIDN'T KNOW THE
GUY FROM ADAM AND HE- WAS ONE
OF THESE FOLKS THAT IMPRESSED
ME BECAUSE THEY LOOKED IN THE
EYE AND HE LISTENED AND ASKED
QUESTIONS. AND HE STUCK AROUND
IN JUST ONE OFF TO THE OTHER
EVENT. THAT MAN WAS CHARLES
JERMAINE LEWIS BETTER KNOWN. AS
JERRY LEWIS THE POLITICIAN
JERRY LEWIS. HE WAS SO SOMEONE
WHERE ALTHOUGH HE WAS
CONSERVATIVE IN HIS VIEWS OF
PANAMA'S POLITICAL TRADITION OF
CIVILITY COOPERATION
CONGENIALITY HE WAS AN
ARCHETYPE BIPARTISAN LEGISLATOR.
WHILE HIS SPEAKER NEWT GINGRICH
STOP POLITICS AS WAR BY ANOTHER
MEANS JERRY LEWIS THOUGHT
POLITICS AS A WAY TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS. AND HE DID EXACTLY
THAT IN THE ASSEMBLY HE
SUCCESSFULLY PUSHED FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE FIRST AIR
QUALITY COMMITTEE WHICH LED TO
THE FORMATION OF THE SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT IN CONGRESS HE WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO UNCOVER FRAUD AND
ABUSE IN HOUSING. HE STEERED
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TOWARD
VITAL INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
IN CALIFORNIA. WORKED ON STEM
CELL AND WORK HARD AT LOMA
LINDA UNIVERSITY FOR THE PROTON
BEAM TREATMENT CENTER. A REAL
STEP FORWARD IN TECHNOLOGY. A
LIFELONG SWIMMER CONGRESSMAN
LEWIS WAS KNOWN TO SWIM FOR A
HUNDRED LAPS TODAY IN THE HOUSE
WING POOL AND IMPRESSIVELY
SAVING THEN HOUSE SPEAKER JIM
WRIGHT. FROM DROWNING IN HAWAII
IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES. HE
WAS NOTHING LESS THAN
EXTRAORDINARY PERSON WHO
DESERVES OUR RESPECT HE PASSED
AWAY. ON JULY FIFTEENTH OF
AFTER A LIFETIME OF PUBLIC
SERVICES I SUGGEST. I CLOSE
WITH THE WORDS OF MITCH ALL
BORN WHO ONCE WROTE. WE MOVED
TO PLACES EVERY DAY THAT WOULD
NEVER HAVE BEEN IF NOT FOR
THOSE WHO CAME BEFORE US. OUR
WORK PLACE HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHERE WE SPEND SO
MUCH TIME WE OFTEN THINK THEY
BEGAN WITH OUR OWN ARRIVAL.
THAT IS NOT TRUE. MEMBERS LET'S
BEAR IN MIND AS WE REFLECT ON
THE LIE AND LEGACY. OF A
BRILLIANT LEGISLATOR JERRY
LEWIS ACID WE CHURN. IN HIS
MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR HER
TADO. TODAY I ASKED THE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF
DEPUTY PHILIP COMP US WHO WAS
KILLED IN THE LINE OF DUTY ON
JULY TWENTY FIFTH DEPUTY
COMPASS WAS KNOWN TO MANY FOR
HIS BIG HEART TENACITY AND HIS
DEDICATION TO HIS COMMUNITY. HE
RECEIVED A CALL ON JULY TWENTY
FIFTH BUT THERE WERE REPORTS OF
GUNSHOTS AT A HOME IN THE CITY
OF WASCO. A SUSPECT HAD
BARRICADED. HIMSELF IN THE HOME
WHAT PROMPTED THE SWAT TEAM TO
BE ACTIVATED AS A MEMBER OF THE
SWAT TEAM DEPUTY CAMPUS
RESPONDED IT WAS SHOT. HE LATER
DIED OF HIS INJURIES DEPUTY
COMPASS IS A HERO. OR BECOMING
A SHERIFF'S DEPUTY HE SERVED IN
THE UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS
WHERE HE WAS DEPLOYED TO
AFGHANISTAN. WELL AT THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT HE NOT
ONLY TWENTY RECRUITS BUT HE
ALSO SERVED IN KERN COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE HONOR GUARD.
HIS LIFE OF SERVICE IS ONE THAT
SHOULD BE ADMIRED AND HONORED.
HE WAS A DEFINITION OF SELFLESS
AND HE RAN TOWARDS DANGER WHEN
OTHERS SOUGHT REFUGE. HIS
COWORKERS AND FRIENDS SAY HE
WAS A WARRIOR AND A NATURAL
BORN LEADER SOMEONE WHO
CHALLENGE THOSE AROUND HIM AND
WHO. WANTED YOU IN HIS CORNER.
HE HAS A HUSBAND WHO LEAVES
BEHIND HIS WIFE CHRISTINA AND A
FATHER WHO LEAVES BEHIND HIS
THREE CHILDREN. I ASKED THE
DEPUTY COMPASS AND HIS SERVICE
BE MEMORIALIZED HERE TODAY AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. WE
USE A STANDARD ROAD ON THE SIDE
OF. TO RAISE AN ACID TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF A PHILIP COMPASS
HE WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY
INDIVIDUAL IS MY COLLEAGUE AT
THIS YEAR'S KERN COUNTY SAYS
I'M HE'S ACTUALLY MY CONSISTED
CONSTITUENT. BUT THE INCIDENT
THAT TOOK HIS LIFE WAS IN
MOSCOW WHEN MY COLLEAGUES
DISTRICT BESIDES THE UNITED
STATES MILITARY MARINE CORPS
VETERAN HE HAD AN INFECTIOUS
SMILE HE PARTICIPATED WHEN HE
GOT INVOLVED IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
IN THE TRAINING ACADEMY. AND HE
HAD AN IMPACT ON ALMOST EVERY
OFFICER THAT WENT TO THE
TRAINING ACADEMY FOR THE LAST
FIVE YEARS HE WAS AN INCREDIBLE
INDIVIDUAL AND WAS ALWAYS
SUCCESSFUL HE LOVED TO RIDE
HORSES HE WOULD BRANDON GATHER
IN RIDE HORSES OUT IN- MY
COMMUNITY. OUT WHERE I LIVE
AND- OUR NEIGHBOR'S CAT ACCOUNT
WAY POLLING AND IS WHAT WE CALL
AN IN CAB WE JAMMED THEY WOULD
TAKE HIM OUT AND TEACH HIM HOW
TO BE A REAL COWBOY. M. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WAS LOST IN
THIS TRANSLATION- THAT WE
DIDN'T COVER- AND I APPRECIATE
MY COLLEAGUES REMARKS VERY MUCH
IS THAT HE HE DIED A HERO WHICH
HE SAID BUT HE DIED A HERO
SAVING A FAMILY. ARE TRYING TO
SAVE A FAMILY THIS WAS A
HORRIFIC INCIDENT THAT RAVAGED
OUR COMMUNITY WE HAD A FATHER
AT GUNPOINT A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATION KILLHIS WIFE. AND
HIS TWO SONS AND TRY TO KILL
HIS TWO DAUGHTERS IF IT WASN'T
FOR OFFICER CAMPOS SWAT TEAM
MEMBER CAMPUS- I'M YOU KNOW
TRYING TO RUSH THE FRONT DOOR
THOSE TWO LITTLE GIRLS WOULD'VE
PROBABLY LOST THEIR LIFE AS
WELL. A THEY REMAIN IS FAMILY
THE WIFE. OF THE PERPETRATOR
THAT THE INDIVIDUAL THAT
COMMITTED THIS HORRIFIC CRIME.
AT LOST THESE TWO LITTLE GIRLS
LOST THEIR MOM. AND THEIR TWO
BROTHERS IN THIS PROCESS. THIS
HORRIFIC ACT RAVAGED OUR
COMMUNITY. M. TORE APART- THE
HEARTS OF THE SWAT TEAM THAT
SERVED SO VALIANTLY. AND NEXT
TO SIT M. OFFICER PHILLIP
CAMPUS. FOR A LONG TIME SEVERAL
YEARS. AND HE EXCELLED AT
EVERYTHING BUT HIS MAIN
OBJECTIVE THAT WEIGHT DOWN THAT
DAY WAS TO TRY TO SAVE AS MANY
LIVES AS POSSIBLE. IN A
HORRIFIC SITUATION. AND IT WAS
HIS HEROISM THAT SAVE THOSE TWO
LITTLE GIRLS LIFE. SO I ASK YOU
TO ENTER IN THE MEMORY OF
PHILIP CAMPUS. THERE AMERISAFE
ANALLY IN PLEASE COVER THIS
ENTIRE SITUATION IN PRAYER AS
YOU THINK ABOUT IT. BECAUSE
THESE TWO LITTLE GIRLS ARE-
THAT WERE LEFT BY THE FATHER
WHO PERPETRATED THE ACT. AND
THEIR LIFE IS GOING TO BE
FOREVER DESTROYED. AND PHILIP
CAMPUSES FAMILY- HIS WIFE- IN
THERE HIS THREE CHILDREN- HAVE
LOST A HERO IN THEIR DADDY AND
SO I WOULD ASK THAT YOU RETURN
THERE MA'AM IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU SENATORS- PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES FORWARD TO THE
DESK SO THEY CAN BE PROPERLY.
MEMORIALIZED BY THE SENATE.
WITH THAT FIVE THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS TODAY. SENATOR
ACTIONS THE DESK IS CLEAR THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT
OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS
SCHEDULED FOR THIS THURSDAY
AUGUST NINETEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. AT NINE AM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR RECKONS THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME
THE GERMAN MOTION WILL BE
PLACED. WE WILL RECONVENE
THURSDAY AT NINE AM AND JUST AS
A QUICK REMINDER APPROPRIATIONS
WILL RECONVENE. SHORTLY IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.